you gotta be why you realize how many  people have read this I'm up to 2,000  followers since last night the trending  bro they're sending me messages that go  to me it's responding doing doing though  I know they had the people saying he's  right yeah but half the people are  saying he's wrong that's the minute  that's right social media hey hey hey  what are you doing so do it what are you  writing chef don't that's not a good  idea  just listen I won't send it until we all  say it's okay why don't you come by  again tonight I got a whole new menu  just for you [ __ ] no no I'm good  don't do it that's out there now so  happens take that back you know what I  threw down the gauntlet